pour le Canadien de Montréal.
Marc Bergevin quitte
l'organisation avec un bilan
mitigé, un peu moi a a a a a a .
Depuis quelques semaines,
le divorce semblait inéluctable.
Le propriétaire, Geoff Molson,
de le laisser écouler la
dernière année de son contrat.
Puis, on apprenait samedi soir
son successeur avait commencé.
Bergevin part au moment où
l'équipe connaît le pire début
d'histoire.
Par communiqué, il a dit
s'en aller la tête haute.
Il a également tenisisisisisisi.
ouououous Bergevin, le Tricolora
atteint les plus hauts sommets,
mais a aussi pataugé
La présence en finale de laCoup,
demeure son plus haut
fait d'armes. o o o o o o o o os
été pénibles avec le départ
de Phillip Danault, la retraite
forcée de Shea Weber
et les problèmes ...............
À peine 144 jours
après avoir atteint la finale,
l'équipe croupit au 29e rang
Leieieieien a aussi raté
les séries quatre fois
lors des six dernières saisons.e
de P.K. Subban en retour
de Shea Weber l'aura marqué
au fer rouge., , , , , , , , , n
équipe de recrutement amateur
a été largement critiqué
pour ses mauvaises décisions.ch,
Trevor Timmins, a aussi été
congédié dimanche.
Le Canadien se tourne
d'un nouveau directeur généralti
devra parler français,
a assuré Geo L L L L L L L L L é
l'ancien DG des Rangers
de New York, Jeff Gorton,
pour l'aider dans sa tâche.
de Mathieu Darche
et de Martin Madden circulent
déjà. Après des mois à avoir
év
brisera le silence lundi matin.
Ici Alexandre Gasco